[MUSIC PLAYING]
KALYAN REDDY: My name
is Kalyan Reddy.
ERIC KOLEDA: And we're here
again with another episode of
Google Apps Unscripted.
This is our once a month show
where we talk about Google
Apps Script in kind of
a free form way.
So we do a little bit of news,
events, some updates, and then
basically are here to answer
your questions.
If you have questions about
Google Apps Script, there's a
couple ways you can get in touch
with us and join into
the show today.
The first is we have a
live Hangout going.
There's a link in the page for
this event, the + page as well
as a page on
developers.google.com.
So you can join the Hangout.
If you have a camera and mic,
ask us a question live.
If you don't have that equipment
or you're a little
shy, you can, of course, click
on the link to the Google
Moderator, which is a place
where you can post questions.
And we'll be getting to those
later in the show.
So, yeah.
Let's kick things off.
We have-- it's been a couple
weeks since we had our last
episode and there's been
some news since then.
So one of the big things that
we've done in Apps Script in
the past couple weeks is launch
Data Validation support.
So, Kalyan, what is
data validation?
KALYAN REDDY: So, Data
Validation is actually one of
our top feature requests.
It's been there for a while.
Here, I'll go to our
blog post here.
Data Validation is actually a
Spreadsheets feature where you
can apply validation rules
to certain cells.
And say that when someone enters
a value, you either
flag it with a little red
triangle at the end, saying
this is not in a particular
range, or it's not in the list
of values that you want.
Or you could just not allow
certain values that aren't
what you expect.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I feel like it's really handy
when you have a spreadsheet
that many people are editing,
and you want to make sure that
the content that they're putting
into the spreadsheet
is valid, it's not like a bad
value, or something that's
going to mess up.
You want to limit their choices
down to either a
number in a certain range
or something on a list.
Right.
KALYAN REDDY: Or, for example,
if you're just collecting what
cities to go on a road trip, you
can put the cities in the
US on the list or something.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, limit the
data to the valid data instead
of everything.
And so Apps Script is really
being used, I think primarily
historically, and still probably
the most today, in
Google Spreadsheets.
It's a really great tool for
adding extra functionality to
a Google spreadsheet.
And so, although we've had the
ability to change values, set
background colors, it wasn't
until this past month that we
added the ability to
programmatically create, edit,
remove this kind of data
validation logic in a
spreadsheet.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, why don't
we take a look at the blog
post and then maybe we
could run through the
quick example in there.
If you want to check this out
yourself it's in our developer
blog, googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com.
Here it is.
Let's see.
You want to run through this
example here, Eric?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So we can kind of show
you a little bit
about what we're doing.
So we have two short
examples here.
One is showing you how you can
just very quickly add data
validation to a cell that didn't
have it before, or
rather, to overwrite the data
validation regardless of
what's there.
So this one is very simple where
it's doing one of the
most popular forms of data
validation, limit the options
in the cell to only the
values in this range.
So we're taking the range B1:B10
that has our values we
want to use.
And then we're grabbing the
range A1, which is where we
want to apply this new
data validation.
And then we have a small builder
pattern that you can
see there that allows you to
create these data validations.
So you say SpreadsheetApp,
newDataValidation.
And then this data validation
should require a
value in the range.
And then there's the range
there, B1 to B10.
And then dot build.
And then now we have a new
data validation object.
KALYAN REDDY: And so just a
background on the builder
pattern real quick.
Every method that you call
here, it returns the data
validation object so you can
chain these successive calls
and say, require values
in this range, do it
for this, et cetera.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, if you're
new to Apps Script, this
chaining looks a little
strange sometimes, but
essentially, every method you
apply returns the original
object back to you again.
And there that allows you to
keep, well, I guess the
modified object back to you
again so you can keep
operating on it.
KALYAN REDDY: And when you
call build at the end, it
changes from the builder object
to the actual final
built object that you can pass
to your other functions.
ERIC KOLEDA: So then you take
that built data validation and
just call set data validation,
passing it in.
And now that cell will have the
data validation applied.
Now, you know, that's great to
add one time data validations,
but really the power of
scripting is to do something
complex that you wouldn't want
to do yourself by hand, right?
By hand I could easily add
that data validation.
And so this second example here,
it shows you something
where really having
the ability to
script comes in handy.
So the situation here is,
let's say you had a
spreadsheet where all your data
validations were based
upon I want to limit the person
to only taking a date
in this current calendar year.
All right.
So you have all these cells with
the data validation on
these cells is set to only
a date within 2013.
Well now suddenly year's
over, 2014 is here.
I want to make a copy
of that spreadsheet.
I want to keep, you know, I want
to allow people to now
focus of the year of 2014.
Well, to go through and find all
the 2013's and swap them
with 2014's could
be a nightmare.
So what we're doing here is
automatically crawling over
all the sheets, all the ranges
within the current sheet-- but
you could easily extend this
to be all sheets within a
spreadsheet--
finding all of the ranges that
have data validation.
And if they were previously set
up to be with this kind of
data validation between January
1, 2013 and December
31, 2013, to swap it
out, to be that
equivalent data in 2014.
KALYAN REDDY: And it's kind of
a more involved example, but
basically this is how you get
all the data validation rules
within the particular range.
And you get the range up here
when you get the active sheet.
And you get the range
for all of it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So, yeah.
It's really nice that we kind
of treat data validation
objects the same way we treated
values or background
colors, where you can take an
entire range, gather up all
the data validation settings
for that entire range, make
modifications, and then save
it all back again.
So that's what you can see at
the very bottom here is that
we built up this array of our
new data validations.
And then at the end, one call,
set data validations, takes
all of the settings we built
up and saves them into the
spreadsheet in one go.
Doing it like this instead of
saving cell by cell by cell,
much faster.
KALYAN REDDY: Definitely.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: And this is like
a general paradigm for
spreadsheets.
You don't ever want to do, I'm
going to get this value, then
the cell next to it, then the
cell next to it, and then keep
changing it and writing it back
because that actually
creates a ton of calls to the
spreadsheet, which make your
script run over the maximum
execution time.
Much better ways to get all the
values as a batch, process
them within your script, and
then write them all.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, definitely.
I've seen dramatic increases in
speed when you just change
that one little paradigm,
so definitely worth
doing from the start.
All right, great.
So that's Data Validation.
We hope people enjoy it.
It was one of our most popular
feature requests
on the issue tracker.
If you're not aware, we do
maintain a issue tracker
that's linked off of our
documentation where you can
file feature requests or bugs.
And one of the feature requests
we had for a long
time was add this feature.
And so we got around to it and
we hope everybody's enjoying
it and happy.
KALYAN REDDY: And this is a good
example of how you can
let us know what the priority
of certain features is.
The Data Validation, for
example, had a ton of people
that were starring the issue
on the issue tracker.
And so that was a signal to us,
basically, that this is
important to you.
And we tried hardest to
get it out there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
The team really relies on people
starring issues as a
way to get a sense of their
relative importance.
So if there's an issue that you
really want to see fixed,
either a bug, or implemented
if it's
something new, star it.
You'll get updates on that
whenever we comment.
And as well, you also indicate
to us that this is something
you really care about.
All right.
Great.
So going from things that we
have added, I'm going to talk
a little bit now on the
other side of things
that are going away.
So we're doing a little bit
of cleaning up of house.
And a while back, we posted how
some of our features are
going to be sunset and
it's going to be
coming up next month.
So we want to make sure people,
if you missed that
original announcement,
are aware.
So the two things that we're
sunsetting, I think it's on
the 16th, is GUI Builder,
as well as four Ui App
components.
So Ui App is one of the two ways
right now you can build
user interfaces in
Apps Script.
It's one where you use, kind of
like layout, some different
components programmatically,
kind of like add a button
here, add a textbox there.
And there are some components
that just never
quite worked right.
And we realized that there's
now, with the HTML service,
other better ways to accomplish
the same goal.
So those four at the top there--
hyperlink, inline
hyperlink, layout panel,
and rich text area--
those are going to be shut
down on September 16.
KALYAN REDDY: And by the way,
the page that you're looking
at here is our sunset schedule
page that you can get in the
App Script page by
going to Support
and then Sunset Schedule.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So because those never really
worked correctly to begin
with, we hope that this
will have a very
low impact on people.
But if it is in your code, you
may start getting an error if
you try to, if you're
still creating one.
So, you might want to go through
some of your code that
you know could have this
and maybe clean it up.
And then GUI Builder is a drag
and drop tool for building Ui
App interfaces.
So in Ui App, you can use a
code to add all of these
components.
And GUI Builder was a way that
without code you could drag a
button here, drag
a textbox there.
We found that it really wasn't
getting the use that we were
hoping it was going to get.
And for other technical
reasons we've
decided to turn it off.
So we've had the word deprecated
in the menu item
for GUI Builder for a little
while now, but come September
16 we're actually going
to shut down the
GUI Builder as well.
Now what that means is that if
you have built in GUI in the
past using GUI Builder, you
won't be able to edit it and
you won't be able to create
any new ones.
But, for at least for the time
being, if you have built a GUI
Builder and you're using it
in the serving of your
application, we'll continue
to serve up that
old GUI Builder interface.
So if you already built a GUI
Builder, I think now's a good
time to start thinking
about how you want to
migrate off of that.
And I think you'll want to look
into using HTML service,
would be our best
recommendation, but you can
also just use regular Ui App.
And now's a good time to get
off of that because once we
take away the GUI Builder
interface, you're not going to
be able to make any more
changes to that Ui.
KALYAN REDDY: Yup.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
I think now we're to talk about
release notes, right?
KALYAN REDDY: Do you want
to talk about AdSense?
ERIC KOLEDA: Right, AdSense.
Good thought.
So this is not exactly an Apps
Script specific thing, but in
Apps Script we have a section
of our documentation called
advanced services.
These are a way that you can use
regular Google APIs, the
ones that are available to the
whole world, and kind of very
easily make requests to
them in Apps Script.
And so what we're doing here is
just, very much, is taking
the APIs everyone else uses
and just giving it to you.
What that means is that when
those APIs decide to change--
get rid of versions,
add new versions--
you have to be a little
bit aware.
And so, for instance, the
AdSense API which we've had
available now for a while,
they've shut down, I believe,
Version 1 and Version 2 and you
can only use Version 3.
I think it might be 1.1 and
1.2, and you can use 1.3.
But regardless, they have
already done that.
That happened in this week--
earlier in August.
But so, if you run into that,
if you realize that you got
caught up in that, it is
important that if you use one
of these advanced services to
know that you are using
another Google product's API,
and they may have decisions
about when they do sunsets,
how long they support a
version for, and you just kind
of need to stay on top of that
a little bit.
KALYAN REDDY: So you can easily
see what these services
are in our developer page under
the Reference It's under
these Advanced Google
Services tab.
So these are the ones that are
kind of packaged external APIs
that we just don't have
easier access to.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And so if you went to the
AdSense API homepage, I think
they'd have some messages there
about these versions
going away.
And so we just honored that same
sunset schedule that they
had in Apps Script.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
So let's talk about
release notes.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
KALYAN REDDY: So we've had a
couple releases since our last
Unscripted at the end of July.
So here I'll start with
the August 5 one.
We added the message,
getPlainBody to the Gmail
message class.
And what this basically does is
returns the content of the
message if you don't care
about any of the HTML
formatting, you just want to get
what is the text here so I
can operate on it.
Then you can easily do this
without writing your own regex
script to HTML, which is
a nightmare, and you
should not do it.
ERIC KOLEDA: That really can be
a-- there's a couple times
when I needed to parse
in a message.
I really just wanted the bare
minimum of the text.
I really didn't care about the
markup they had, tables, so
that was really nice to add.
KALYAN REDDY: It's kind of a
handy utility method where
it's just like skimming
the text.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, give
it to me straight.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see.
There's a couple deprecations.
So as, we've announced before,
we've added the Drive App
service, which is
a replacement to
the DocsList service.
And what we're showing here is
that some of the methods that
used to be in the DocsList we
deprecated because they're
already equivalent with
Drive App as well.
So for example, find, get all
files, get all folders--
these are methods that take a
start value and then a maximum
number of results the
returned value.
We're deprecating those in favor
of the Drive App or the
paging methods within the
DocsList, which actually
return you a token, which you
can use for, it's called
continuation, which is basically
I've processed
everything up until
this token.
I'm going to give you this
token, give me some more
results starting
at this token.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So the key here is that although
Drive App is the
future, you can still continue
to use DocsList right now.
It has not been deprecated
as of yet.
But we had these certain
methods that--
there's just different back
end reasons were not very
efficient and there's better
paging methods out there in
DocsList like to get something
for paging method.
So we encourage you,
if you're using the
DocsList, try using Drive.
But if you need to use DocsList,
use these paging
methods instead for getting a
larger numbers of results.
If you just need to get-- if you
just need to get the first
10 files, you'll be fine.
But a lot of times people
want all the files.
And all the files can
be a lot of files.
Some Drive people power
users out there.
They have quite a number of
files in their Drive.
KALYAN REDDY: Right
OK, let's see.
A couple of issues were fixed.
One is the feature request
we talked about, the data
validation rules.
If we talked in a previous
episode about the Google Drive
SDK that allows you to download
your Apps Script
source files onto your computer
so that you can
upload them to a source control
repository or write a
plugin But, like we mentioned
before, someone wrote a plugin
for the Sublime Text editor that
allows them to edit Apps
Script files and
re-upload them.
There was a bug in it where HTML
files were being uploaded
under the server JS
type, which is
usually for code files.
And that has since
been resolved.
So now they should be
uploaded as HTML.
Let's see, special characters
don't need
to hit escape twice.
So if you did have a script
where you were double escaping
special characters, you no
longer need to do that.
And when-- and this
is a key thing.
So if you disabled Drive App in
the domain administration
panel, this only applies when
you're using Drive App within
a domain, when your script
is in a domain account.
If your administrator has
disabled Drive Apps, then
Drive App now throws an
appropriate error message.
It's not going to function, but
before it used a generic
server error, and now it clearly
says you don't have
permission to do this, you're
not allowed to do this.
And then you can contact your
administrator to find out why,
because Apps Scripts
are awesome.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
You know, there's a lot of times
in Apps Script where
we'll give you an error
message and
sometimes you're like what?
What was that?
I don't know what
to do with this.
So if that does happen,
let us know.
I think this is a case where
someone reported it.
Let us know and we can go in
there and come up with a more
appropriate error message that
allows you to better determine
what went wrong, maybe how you
work around it, or fix your
code to not run into
that error.
KALYAN REDDY: Yup.
We added a convenience method
spreadsheet.deleteSheet where
you can specify the
actual sheet.
So before what we had was you
can delete the active sheet,
so you have to make the sheet
an active sheet and then you
called delete sheet and it
would get rid of it.
But this is if you don't want
to switch what the active
sheet is, you can just
provide a name.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see, and the
last release on August 19,
we added more convenience
methods to
the Drive App service.
One is a make copy where you can
provide the destination.
The old make copy method, you
call it on the file itself and
it would make the copy within
the same directory of where
the original was, or
the route, I think.
But this one, in any case,
allows you to specify a folder
where the copy should go.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think it
was in the same directory as
the file you're copying.
And the problem there was that
if someone shared with you a
folder in read-only mode, if
you tried to make a copy of
that file, which you should be
able to do, it would make that
copy right in the folder you
had read-only access to.
And so it failed.
So now you can make a copy of
a file in a read-only folder
and make it into a folder that
you do have write access to.
So, we'll book it after that.
KALYAN REDDY: And the last thing
here, well there was a
performance issue that affected
certain scripts that
no longer occurs.
Kind of cryptic,
but most people
weren't affected by this.
And if you were, we apologize
for that and we've since
applied a fix that should
relieve that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, now, App
Script isn't necessarily ultra
fast in all scenarios.
But if you do see something
where something that used to
only take a second or two is now
taking 10, 20, 30, if you
actually have-- if you can point
to us, here's the code
that's running really slow, do
let us know because we do want
to make sure that if there's any
sort of performance change
that's coming about that
we can look into that.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
And just the fact that
everything runs on the cloud,
you can't guarantee exactly
the same performance every
single iteration of every loop,
but you can using the
execution transcript, which is
a feature we recently added,
you can get timings for
this and then you can
use your best judgment.
If something used to take five
seconds total and is now
taking five minutes, then
there's clearly something
wrong there.
So that's something worth
discussing, whereas if it was
taking five seconds and now
it's taking seven seconds,
that could be like a transient
thing, or it could just be the
fact that it's running
on a lot of stuff
servers in the back end.
ERIC KOLEDA: There's so many
different reasons that those
things can change, but if
there's patterns, if we see
that, hey, all the time, or 9
times out of 10, this thing is
running way slow, that's
important for us to know.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
KALYAN REDDY: So for release
notes, you want
to jump to the Hangout?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I think our
producers says we have a few
people in the Hangout.
And I also saw here, Luca, you
mentioned that you can't see
the screen we're sharing
on the Hangout,
I'm sorry about that.
Yeah, that is a limitation, but
you get to be here live,
so that's the plus side.
LUCA: All right, thanks guys.
ERIC KOLEDA: Do you have any
questions for us today?
LUCA: Well actually I
posted some on the
moderator, that's it.
But specifically, actually,
there's one where I haven't
posted, but I uploaded, which
is kind of interesting.
The idea is that so you can kind
of publish versions, but
you can not reverse your code
to a specific version, so I
was wondering if maybe that's
in the pipeline
of things to address?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, people have
been asking for that since we
introduced versions.
I think, when we put out
versions, it was about the
time that we were launching, I
think, libraries and web apps.
And I think the main goal there
was that we're giving
your code to someone else, you
want to make sure there's
stability so you can keep
developing, but that someone
who's utilizing it either as a
web app or in a library, gets
the concrete, fixed version
that you know worked.
The natural extension of that
though is to say, hey, what
about reverting my
code, right?
If I make a version that works
and I totally mess it up in my
development process, I want to
go back to the version that
worked myself.
And that's not there today, and
we have talked about that.
There is in the script editor
a way for you to see your
revision history.
However, that isn't really
version aware.
It's kind of every time you, I
think, hit save you'll get
another entry in there.
And we only save so many, so
it's not quite the same as
having reverting to versions.
KALYAN REDDY: It is kind of
noisy and not fully useful in
that sense but, unfortunately
this isn't completely
packaged, but the way to do
this now, the work around,
would be to use the Drive SDK
and you can snapshot your
files at any point, and then you
can use your own version
control in that way.
Yeah, unfortunately it isn't
like a package solution.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, one of the
things we're trying to, I
think we always try to work
out in Apps Script, is how
much do we want to create a tool
and how much we want to
allow you to use a tool that
you may already be using.
So a lot of people love using
GitHub for instance, to manage
that code and version it.
So we're trying to figure out
how much should we build our
own thing and how much we
utilize kind of the developer
tools that are already
out there.
So I think we'll continue to
look into it, specifically in
the versioning case.
And we'll see how things
turn out there.
LUCA: All right, thanks.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thank you.
KALYAN REDDY: Any more questions
in the Hangout?
All right, let's jump to
the moderator here.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, we'll leave
the mics running so if you
guys have questions in between,
feel free to ask away.
KALYAN REDDY: We got some
great questions here.
Let's see.
So Eric, for a file in Google
Drive, getEditors() or
getViewers() is not available
in DriveApp,
it's only in DocsList.
Is this supported in the future
in DriveApp class, or
do we still need to DocsList?
ERIC KOLEDA: It's a very
good question.
So the reason it's not in
DiveApp today is because the
Drive product--
I think Google in general has
kind of shifted away from
making your email address a
piece of public information.
So for instance, if you're in
a doc and someone joins and
starts editing.
Or if you look in the sharing
dialogue inside Google Drive,
you'll actually see someone's
name, their
face, but you won't--
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI:
Hello, hello.
ERIC KOLEDA: --have to see
their email address.
And so I think what we're trying
to do here is in Drive
App reflect that same paradigm,
where someone's
email address won't be
necessarily available to just
because you have access
to their document.
So we know this is a problem
for people who are building
apps that do things, like making
sure that someone has
access or doesn't have
access, you know,
monitoring who has access.
So we are working on adding some
more features to Drive
App that allows you to get
closer to the same information
you have in DocsList but it may
be that we come up with a
different solution for Drive
App than there was in
DocsList, rather than
just return to
people's email addresses.
So stay tuned for that hopefully
we'll have more news
for you in the future.
I think long term, though,
DocsList is not there to be
kind of like in addition to
Drive App DocsList is an older
technology and I think we're
encouraging people to move to
Drive App when possible.
And if there are things like
this that prevent you from
moving to Drive App, thank you
so much for bringing them up
because we do want to make sure
that you have the ability
to move your functionality
off the DocsList.
I think I heard someone
new join the Hangout.
Do you have a question?
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI: Hello.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes, hello.
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI:
Can you hear me?
ERIC KOLEDA: I can.
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI: OK, thanks.
I'm Luciano from Brazil.
I want to ask is there any plan
to add download as HTML
at the zip it folder
into Apps Script.
Currently we can only download
it as a PDF and since we can
turn interface download it as
HTML, zip it folder it would
be sure nice to be able to do
it from the Apps Script.
ERIC KOLEDA: Are you referring
to a Google Docs file?
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI: Yes.
A Google Docs file in a native
document in Drive.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right, yeah.
So yeah, there is
that ability.
There are actually, yeah.
If you go to Google Docs or even
Google Sheets, there are
a lot more options under the
download menu bar than there
are inside of App
Script today.
All right, I think we just as
you mentioned PDFs today
inside Apps Script.
We are aware that people kind of
really want to have access
to more file types, whether it
be exporting to an Open Office
file type or to like you
mentioned, to HTML.
We want to make more of those
available in Apps Script.
It's been something we've talked
about for a while, and
I'll bring it back up with the
team again and make sure that
they're aware that people are
still asking for this.
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI:
OK, thank you.
KALYAN REDDY: Anyone else
in the Hangout?
All right, let's continue
with these questions.
This save versions, we already
answered this question.
Just now from Santy.
It'd be great if we could
develop a full blown website
using Apps Script, but currently
cannot map a script
to a domain.
Is there a way I can do it?
ERIC KOLEDA: Hm, yes.
SANTY: You asked me,
be straight.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes,
good question.
Unfortunately it's not
possible today.
So one of the things we wanted
to do with the Apps Script web
apps was make it very
easy to deploy.
Right.
It's actually just one small
dialogue, you say what
version, you say the access,
you hit deploy,
you're done, right?
You compare that to launching
a website under almost any
other platform and it's many,
many steps quicker.
I think one of the downsides of
that is that it's also less
configurable, right?
So I think--
if you think about Apps Script
web apps sometimes it would be
nice to launch something
full-blown, but I think we're
not trying to solve
that problem.
There's a lot of great products
at Google and outside
Google that allow you to build
websites and web apps.
And I think, to actually, to
do that right requires some
tools and some features
that just aren't
in Apps Script today.
And so I think when you think
about Apps Script web apps,
it's probably best to think
about small tools, things to
use within an organization,
utilities, you know, something
that's kind of small in scope.
And for those we hope that run
them off script.google.com
would be enough, but do let us
know, I guess, if that won't
work for those kind
of use cases.
But we definitely want, we're
definitely trying to encourage
people to think of web apps in
Apps Script as meant for
solving smaller problems, not
launching a business or
something of that nature.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
And if you do want to make a
full-blown website, that's one
of the indications that you
should move on to something
like App Engine, which lets you
have more control over the
configuration and deployment
aspect.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And some people, what they do is
they'll prototype something
in App Script because, like I
mentioned, you can get it
running really quickly, we have
all these integrations
into Google services.
So you can make a kind of like
prototype version of an App
you want to build really
quickly, show it around to
people, get feedback.
And then when you're time to
really like make the final
production version then maybe
you look into another platform
like App Engine.
I'd say that would probably be
our answer for right now.
KALYAN REDDY: OK, next question
here is can I pull a
list of values from a
spreadsheet into my form so
that each time the form is
opened it will update with the
most current list of values.
Yes.
ERIC KOLEDA: And the
answer is yes.
So not only can you do this
yourself with the Form App,
which is another integration
into Google Forms that we
launched for I/O this year, and
I gave a presentation on.
If you want to see it, I think
it's a really good I/O
presentation, I'm
a little biased.
But not only can you build it
yourself and actually Form App
is very easy to use.
But, one of the kind of like
top contributors and most
popular scripters out there
for Apps Script Andrew
Stillman who works in the
education space, he built a
script I believe it's called
Form Ranger that does exactly
this-- allows you to take a
range within your spreadsheet
and tie it into a form field
so that whenever the range
changes, the form
gets updated.
So, yeah.
Certainly possible and
you may not even have
to write any code.
Although, if you like to write
code, it wouldn't be hard and
I think you'd actually
learn a lot too.
All right.
KALYAN REDDY: All right, any
questions on the Hangout?
Feel free to jump in.
We'll leave your mics up and
we can hear you there.
OK.
You want to continue
with the moderator?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, yeah.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
Apps Script deployed as a web
app to run in the context of
the user who runs it, targeted
for more than 10,000 users.
ERIC KOLEDA: Woah.
KALYAN REDDY: Is there a limit
on the number of concurrent
hits for web app or any other
limit not listed in the App
Script dashboard that should
be of potential concern?
ERIC KOLEDA: So, we haven't
got this question before,
which is like what are the
limits of how much, is there
bandwidth limits on upload or
download from a web app or
concurrent request
to a web app.
We don't have anything
published, but I do want to
echo back to what I had said
to the previous question
there, that we really don't
think that Apps Script is the
right tool if you're going to
have 10K concurrent users, I
get technically users
in general.
But when you're really looking
at something that needs to
scale to a lot of people, really
like a production level
web application, we think that
Apps Script may not be the
best choice.
If we just--
if you see what's there, we
don't really have the
information about those kind
of details right now.
Although, we can look
into getting it.
But we also have some of the
tooling around, like
monitoring, that you'd want to
see if you're building a large
scale web application.
KALYAN REDDY: Logging,
et cetera.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So I would recommend against
launching that on Apps Script,
but you're certainly
welcome to try.
We have had someone in the
past who launched a very
popular web app for their
organization that used
ScriptDb and they did run
into some quotas.
So maybe there's not going to
be a limit on the web app
serving side, but the pieces
of Apps Script that you're
using, whether it be Gmail app
for sending emails, or the
spreadsheet app for sending
spreadsheets, or ScriptDb for
storing data, those all have
their own individual quotas
that are more targeted at an
individual use case kind of
level of quotas and not really
geared up for a full scale
large application.
KALYAN REDDY: And the poster
mentioned in the question that
is deployed to run in the
context of the user, which
definitely helps
in that regard.
ERIC KOLEDA: It helps with the
quotas a little bit and
running in the context of the
user, but something like
ScriptDb, for instance, has
limits that are tied to the
developer, so you do want
to be careful there.
KALYAN REDDY: Yup.
All right, next question.
Any news on access to custom
properties on Google Docs from
Apps Script.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
KALYAN REDDY: Are ther
workarounds in the meantime?
ERIC KOLEDA: So, I think this is
that the Google Drive SDK,
they allow you to read and write
small properties to the
document itself.
In Apps Script you can set
properties on your script or
on the user but not
on the document.
So although that exists in the
Drive SDK, it hasn't yet made
it into Drive App we're still
talking about whether that
makes sense.
And I think it should be
possible to call a Drive App--
the Drive SDK from Apps Script
using URL fetch, but you'll
have to do a lot of the plumbing
yourself when it
comes to authorization, in
building the requests.
So it could be a good
deal of work there.
I do know that some of our top
contributors have built
wrapper libraries that allow you
to call into services and
features that we
don't support.
So you may want to investigate
if they've already solved this
problem or if they'd be
willing to add it in.
KALYAN REDDY: And a great place
to look that up is in
the Apps Script community
on +.
ERIC KOLEDA: On Google+,
we have a very
active community there.
KALYAN REDDY: All right,
final question.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, just about
out of time, yeah.
Let's wrap it up.
KALYAN REDDY: All right, final
question is since App Script
web apps are served from a non
Google domain, Google user
content, why can't there be less
restrictions, evaluating
HTML strips, many things,
and cannot
freely set HTTP headers?
ERIC KOLEDA: So I think
Luca's here with us.
I looked into this earlier today
I'm pretty sure it's not
served off Google
user content.
Now, if you're using the HTML
service, it's served off of
scriptgoogle.com If you're using
the content service, it
does do a redirect from
scriptgoogle.com to Google
user content.
But when you're serving HTML
service HTML it is served off
scriptgoogle.com and that allows
you to do some things
like easily integrate other
Google services because you're
already past your Google
information, your login
information to the web page.
Because of that, we do need
to be restrictive.
We don't want someone's
JavaScript code messing with
your session, or doing things
on your behalf other than
they've been authorized to do.
LUCA: OK.
I guess the final thing is, in
my use case was that I needed
to use specific [INAUDIBLE],
like I had to return different
concept types, like
there's one called
application/rdf+xml, something
like that.
And I couldn't do that so I was
just wondering if it's a
little more flexible.
But now that I guess it's like
one of those things that isn't
meant for it to be
used in that way.
ERIC KOLEDA: Ah, got you.
Well so the content service
does allow you to serve
arbitrary file types,
however-- well, not
arbitrary--
serve various file types.
But ones we limit to
a certain enum.
So if there's something that's
missing in there that you
think you'd like to see you can
file a feature request for
that and it's not too much work
for us to add that in.
LUCIANO PANEPUCCI: All right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
All right.
Well I think that does it for
today's episode of Google Apps
Unscripted.
If you have any questions in the
meantime before our next
episode, which is probably going
to be a month from now,
feel free to reach us on
Stack Overflow, or
talk to us on Google+.
And yes, stay tuned to the blog
for more announcements.
Our release notes are updated
weekly by our very own Kalyan.
So yeah, plenty of ways
you can stay in touch
outside of the show.
But if not, we'll see you
again next month.
KALYAN REDDY: Thanks
for joining us.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thanks, everyone.
LUCA: See you guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]